(screaming)
- [Narrator] When a big earthquake hits,
collapsed buildings can bury people alive.
- [Narrator] That's when the legendary
human moles of Mexico City come in.
- [Narrator] And when the moles arrive,
the community comes together as one fist.
(mid-tempo music)
- [Narrator] In 1985, Mexico City was hit
by a devastating earthquake
that killed roughly 10,000 people.
That's when a group of volunteers decided
to form a collective to
help fellow human beings.
- [Narrator] The members of the Topos
undergo intensive training
inside an abandoned park in Mexico City.
To prepare for the next earthquake,
the Topos must stay in
peak physical shape.
They also learn to identify
risks of collapsing buildings
and run simulated rescue missions.
- [Narrator] The Topos are
so good at what they do
that they travel the world
helping other countries
in their moments of despair.
(mid-tempo piano music)